[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOHN DOLHUN: I've
done these demos
in front of live audiences.
I remember one time I did
one demo in front of alumni.
I forget what it was,
but it was a failure.
And this one little kid--
he was only about four years
old-- he raised his hand.
He said, you win some
and you lose some.
SARAH HANSEN: Today
on Chalk Radio,
we're talking about the course
5.310, Laboratory Chemistry.
This is a course
that not only teaches
students about hands-on
science, but also life.
Because working in a lab
is a lot like baking--
you can follow recipes, but
your cake might still collapse.
I'm your host Sarah Hansen.
In this episode, we're
joined by two MIT educators
who have helped shape
this standout course.
They'll tell us
more about what it
looks like to support students
with various academic interests
as they develop lab skills,
overcome setbacks, and apply
their studies to real-world
problems like water quality.
JOHN DOLHUN: I'm John
Dolhun, currently
Director of the Undergraduate
Chemistry Teaching Labs at MIT.
SARAH HEWETT: I'm
Sarah Hewett and I
am a technical instructor in
the Chemistry Department at MIT.
SARAH HANSEN: For many
of their students,
5.310 is the first time they
step foot in a college level
chemistry lab, and that can
be a memorable experience.
JOHN DOLHUN: The first
thing you would see
are lines of student
coat lockers.
And that's the first thing
that students encounter
when they enter the lab.
It's here where they
would put their bags,
and they store their lab
coats and their goggles.
And you would soon see
walking out into the lab
that it's divided into 12 bays.
Each bay has 6 to 7 fume
hoods and desk space
for up to 14 students.
SARAH HANSEN: And lots
and lots of windows--
something I may have
read a bit too much into.
SARAH HEWETT: You
can correct me.
I always thought it was because
in case there's an explosion,
they want all the windows
to blow out instead
of the walls of the building.
JOHN DOLHUN: An-- [LAUGHS]
SARAH HANSEN: Maybe I'm wrong.
JOHN DOLHUN: --explosion.
[LAUGHS]
SARAH HANSEN: John
went on to explain
that yes, you would see windows,
but explosions, not so much.
Anyway, let's get back
to what you actually
would see in this lab.
JOHN DOLHUN: We have some
really neat instruments that
the students can
operate hands-on,
exactly what the students
would experience in industry--
Cary 60 UV-Vis spectrometers,
state of the art
density meters and
refractometers,
and one of the really
exciting instruments
is an inductively coupled
plasma mass spectrometer.
There are only two
of these at MIT.
And this instrument is
used exclusively in 5.310,
and the students actually
use that to test their river
samples to determine the
concentration of 29 different
elements down to the
part per trillion level.
So it's pretty exciting.
SARAH HANSEN: The river sample
testing is part of what makes
5.310 unique.
Students get to take their
lab work right into Boston's
own Charles River.
SARAH HEWETT: Yes.
The most exciting experiment, I
think, for most of the students
is the Ellen Swallow
Richards Lab.
So the students actually
go down to the river
and take water samples.
And then they get to analyze
those samples back up
in the lab for dissolved
oxygen, phosphate concentration,
and a bunch of other elements.
So they get to
learn a little bit
about environmental chemistry,
and analytical chemistry,
and different
techniques that we use
for those types of analysis.
And the students really
like that because it's
very applicable to
the Charles River
and to the Boston environment.
And they can see it
and say, oh, wow, I'm
actually doing something
that's kind of useful
and something that--
they always hear
about how dirty the
Charles River used to be,
and they're actually
kind of surprised
when they do the lab now about
how good the water quality is.
SARAH HANSEN: You
may have caught
that Sarah and John referred
to this as the Ellen Swallow
Richards Lab.
It's a namesake with
significant meaning.
JOHN DOLHUN: When I
wrote this lab in 2010,
I actually called it
the Charles River Lab.
The reason I wrote the lab was
to introduce an environmental
component into the 5.310
Laboratory Chemistry course.
And sometime after
I had wrote the lab,
I actually was walking
through the halls at MIT,
and somehow I ended up in
the lobby of Building 2.
And I looked up and I saw
this plaque and this photo
of this woman on the wall.
And I started reading
it and it said,
this was the first female
student ever admitted to MIT
who graduated in 1873.
It was Ellen Swallow
Richards, who
was an industrial
safety engineer
and environmental chemist.
And it was really
her work, I think,
in 1887 which led to the
first state water quality
standards in the nation.
And that was very
significant, and that kind of
moved me to rename the Charles
River Lab the Ellen Swallow
Richards Lab.
SARAH HANSEN: The groundwork
laid by Ellen Swallow Richards
has never been more important
in a way that feels particularly
relevant for my own community
and likely for some of yours.
SARAH HEWETT: One
of the local issues
that has come up in
the Cambridge area
and around the country is
the issue of PFAS, which
are per- and
polyfluoroalkyl substances,
which are man made chemicals
that have been around
for less than 100 years.
So they're relatively
new, but they
encompass things like
Teflon and other chemicals
like that that are involved
in non-stick coatings for food
and also in fire suppression
technology because they're
really flame resistant,
and stain resistant,
and stick resistant.
So now they're being
detected in water supplies
and in the food
chain, and scientists
are pretty worried about
their impact on human health.
And they're still not entirely
sure what all of the impacts
are, but there's been
a lot of research
recently into detecting
these in the environment
and trying to figure out what
their impact is on health.
SARAH HANSEN: As
you might imagine,
most students aren't ready to go
out into the field on Day 1 one
of 5.310.
The first step is learning
how to be safe in the lab.
And learning how to interact
with chemicals and instruments
in the lab can be daunting.
JOHN DOLHUN: They're coming
in and they're afraid.
Some of them have never, ever
been in a wet lab before.
You've got to make them feel
really comfortable, even
though they might
be a fourth year
student at MIT, graduating.
SARAH HEWETT: The really fun
thing about 5.310 is that there
isn't really a typical student.
We get students from all types
of majors that take the course.
So it's a requirement
for medical school
and it's a requirement for the
chemical engineering major,
so we get a bunch of
chemical engineers
and some med school
or pre-med students.
But they all come from majors
all across the Institute,
which is really fun.
So even though a lot
of them have not taken
a chemistry lab maybe
since high school
or ever, they have a lot of
science knowledge and knowledge
of other things that is
always kind of interesting.
Sometimes after the
lectures they'll come up
and say, oh, this reminds me of
something from my other class.
And that's how I learn a lot,
too, just from talking to them
and hearing about
their experiences.
They actually end up
helping each other.
So some of them who say, oh,
I've worked in a biology lab,
I might have more
experience with pipetting
can help students who
maybe have not taken
a lab class in many years.
SARAH HANSEN: For beginner and
experienced chemistry students
alike, 5.310's labs
are a challenge.
That means John and Sarah
have thought carefully
about what kinds of support
their students might need.
JOHN DOLHUN: Many, many
schools use a lab manual,
and they use experiments that
are very clearly published out.
And the students go through
maybe 12 experiments
in a semester and they're
very systematic in terms
of the types of experiments
that are there--
the traditional experiments.
But with MIT, some
of the experiments
are multi-day,
multifaceted experiments
that are actually put together
and can be quite challenging.
A typical experiment could
be 50 to 60 pages long.
In terms of helping them
deal with frustration,
I believe in divide and conquer.
For example, one of
the things that's
very difficult, and
challenging, and stressful
might be writing
up the lab report.
That might take them
10 to 15 hours of time.
So we teach them
how to break this up
to deal with small
frustrations systematically.
Do small parts of it
early on and don't
wait till the end to
do the whole thing.
It's kind of like them working
on tiny anthills instead
of a big mountain.
And so, by forming
these good habits,
they'll soon be
able to deal with
mountain-sized frustration.
I'm a product of MIT
and it works for me.
SARAH HANSEN: In
addition to building
the perseverance
chemistry requires,
both students and
instructors are also
actively cultivating
curiosity and making
mistakes in the process.
JOHN DOLHUN: Students
love diapers.
And as soon as you
pull a diaper out,
that totally gets them
relaxed and loosens them up.
The polymer demo is all
about sodium polyacrylamide,
and that's the diaper polymer.
That's the chemical in the
diapers that absorbs the water
at 800 times its weight.
[LAUGHS]
When I do this demo, I
usually call on a volunteer.
And unbeknownst
to the volunteer,
I've already put some
powder in the cup.
And I start pouring
water in a cup
and I ask the volunteer
to tell me when to stop.
When they tell me to stop, I
put a plastic cover on the cup,
and turn it over, and then
I put it on their head.
Usually I ask them
to hold it so they
can assume any
responsibility for that water
in the cup coming out.
But usually, nothing comes
out because the polymer has
absorbed all the water, right?
You get this beautiful globular
polymer inside this cup.
And you knock it out into
a dish, and you can see it.
But I remember when I did this
demo at one of the MIT parents'
visiting weekends.
And there were about 70 to
80 people in the audience,
and I asked for a
volunteer to come down.
So he came down, but
he didn't tell me
soon enough to stop pouring
the water in the cup.
So I just kept going
till he said stop, right?
So I covered the cup
up very carefully,
turned it over on
this hard plastic,
and I put it on his head.
And the polymer
and all the water,
when I pulled the card
out, it all came out
and it messed up his hairdo.
It was a gooey, gooey mess,
and the audience just loved it.
I mean, we had to clean him
up with paper towels in front
of everybody.
So there's often unexpected
fun in these live demos.
SARAH HEWETT: Yes.
I think that's one of the
fun parts about the lab,
is that not everything works.
It doesn't work
always for demos.
But even in the lab you can
have two students follow
the exact same
procedure, and sometimes
it just doesn't come out.
Or they'll make one little error
that they didn't even notice,
and then it won't work.
And so that is
definitely something
that we deal with
a lot in the lab--
dealing with that frustration
and having the students
say, well, trying to
figure out what went wrong
and how to fix it for next time.
But that is a big part of
what happens in the lab,
and a big lesson I
think that comes out
that's very unrelated to
chemistry but very important
for life.
SARAH HANSEN: Another
important aspect of this course
is its emphasis on
science communication.
JOHN DOLHUN: A few years
ago, we looked at the course
and we saw the necessity of
writing and for the students
to be able to communicate their
work to a general audience
of non-scientists.
By working with
writing, rhetoric,
and professional
communication instructors,
students learn how to
write and present the paper
to a general audience.
SARAH HEWETT: We came up with
a bunch of different topics
that are related to water
quality, and the Charles River,
and all of the data that
we gather for that lab.
Students can choose which
genre they would like to write.
So some examples
that we have are,
there's a hospital memo
about mercury levels in fish
that we measure with
our mercury analyzer.
So they can use the data to
make arguments about that.
There are policy memos
for the government talking
about why it's important to
limit phosphate concentration
and pollution in the water.
It challenges them
to think about how
to communicate science
in these different ways.
And the writing
instructors have been
amazing in helping
them learn how to write
in these different styles.
I never learned to write science
from a writing perspective--
it was always just in my science
classes from other scientists.
And so I would recommend
it to any other instructor
to bring in writing help if you
have it because it carries over
to their lab reports,
too, because they have
all these skills of how
to read their own work,
and how to assess it for
clarity, and all those things.
SARAH HANSEN: One
thing about MIT faculty
that we love is their commitment
to sharing their teaching
materials with everyone.
I was curious what motivated
Sarah and John to do this.
SARAH HEWETT: Sharing
the course materials
is a really helpful resource
to other instructors
because I know I've benefited
from talking to people that I
went to graduate school with
about what they're doing,
and going to conferences, and
learning from other people.
And so the more that
we can share and make
available these
materials, the more it
can help other
instructors, and also
to introduce more
people to chemistry.
If they have their one
experience of a chemistry
course, then maybe they
can go online and see,
hey, maybe this
other place is taught
in a different way that's
way more interesting,
or, I think that
that's something
that I might like to do.
So I think it benefits
everybody to be
more open with what's going on.
JOHN DOLHUN: OpenCourseWare
has such a good reputation
in terms of people all over
the world that actually
turn to OpenCourseWare
to open a course
and actually learn the
material from that course.
I've had students--
freshman advisees--
who have come in who've
learned everything that they
know from OpenCourseWare.
It's quite dramatic when
you have a student come in
and they literally can
test out of every subject,
but they've learned
all of those subjects
from watching OpenCourseWare.
SARAH HANSEN: Before
we go, I also asked
Sarah and John what they
would like to ask you,
our listeners, about teaching
laboratory chemistry.
JOHN DOLHUN: Yeah.
I think I'd be
curious to know what
demos some of the
other educators
do in their laboratory
chemistry courses,
and also what types of
non-traditional labs
they're running.
SARAH HEWETT: I think
my favorite question
to ask other lab
instructors is, what
is the purpose of teaching lab?
So a lot of people
have different answers
to that, which is always
kind of interesting.
And then, also, another question
that I've been thinking about
is how to prepare
students for what they're
going to be doing next, whether
it's going into industry,
or academia, or pre-med.
What can we do in
the lab to help them
with that, whether it's
chemistry or related or not?
SARAH HANSEN: If you
have insights to share,
please get in touch with me
the link in our show notes.
I'll be sure to pass your
ideas along to John, Sarah,
and other listeners.
If you're interested in learning
more about laboratory chemistry
or remixing Sarah and John's
open educational resources
in your own teaching, head on
over to our MIT OpenCourseWare
website.
Thank you so much for listening.
Until next time, signing off.
From near the Charles River,
I'm your host Sarah Hansen
from MIT OpenCourseWare.
Chalk Radio's producers
include myself, Brett Paci
and Dave Lishanksy.
Scriptwriting assistance
from Aubrey Calaway.
Show notes for this episode
were written by Peter Chipman.
The 5.310 course site was
built by Alicia Franke.
We're funded by MIT Open
Learning and supporters
like you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]